[Musica]
vi faccio una domanda e mi aspetto
sincerità
quanti di voi nella loro vita hanno
almeno fatto una sola volta una dieta
alzino la mano sopra si vede
discretamente bene grazie
quanti di voi nella vostra vita avete
fatto almeno cinque diete siccome voglio
essere buono stamattina non vado oltre e
vi racconto la più grande fair use della
storia di tutti i tempi ovvero che le
diete ipocaloriche facciano dimagrire mi
signori miei
avete perso tempo se c'è una cosa che ha
dimostrato la scienza che la perdita di
peso non avviene mangiando meno e vi
dico e condivido con voi un altro
segreto
oggi molti di voi si saranno pesati
sulla bilancia fanno quella divertente
atto tutti i giorni per dire ma sì
perché non iniziare bene la giornata e
vediamo qual è il numero che segna la
nostra esistenza
vi siete pesati fra una settimana lo
rifarete qualcuno di voi un pò più
ossessivo lo rifarà anche domani e
troverete sempre lo stesso numero
ma quello che voi non sapete quello che
voi ignorate che magari quello stesso
medesimo numero racconta una cosa
totalmente diversa da voi ve lo dimostro
noi siamo fatti sostanzialmente di
quattro cose il nostro corpo acqua per
lo più acqua per lo più muscoli cellule
muscolari ossa grasso l'antipatico
grasso che poi magari riusciremo a dire
che cosa fa ed è molto importante e le
cellule
noi possiamo pensare oggi 70 kg possiamo
pensare i medesimi 70 chili fra una
settimana
ma l'equilibrio tra queste quattro
componenti può essere totalmente diverso
qual è il messaggio non fidatevi mai del
numero
quale messaggio noi anche dal punto di
vista biologico non siamo quel numero io
ho avuto come dire la fortuna
da un certo punto di vista anche la
grande fatica di occuparmi di un tema
che molti di voi conoscono forse
conoscono in modo un po superficiale che
sono i disturbi del comportamento
alimentare io dirigo una struttura una
comunità terapeutica che cerca di curare
ragazze ragazzi affette da anoressia
bulimia obesità e quello che ho potuto
imparare nella mia onorato del
migliorato servizio e la complessità del
rapporto che noi abbiamo col cibo e
quello che rappresenta questa
complessità dal punto di vista della
nostra identità che noi possiamo essere
ossessionati dalla magrezza che noi
possiamo essere schiavi di un corpo che
in qualche modo tende a essere
sovrappeso il messaggio che dobbiamo
cercare di recuperare il messaggio che
ho imparato dalle storie di ogni singola
ragazza che ho tentato di curare e di
cosa di prezioso ed importante si
nasconde nel rapporto tra noi e il cibo
vi racconto la storia di federica
federica la ragazza di 22 anni che viene
a trovarmi perché affetta da quella che
volgarmente verrebbe definita bulimia
nervosa la bulimia nervosa è un tipico
disturbo del comportamento alimentare
caratterizzato dal fatto che una ragazza
ad un certo punto un ragazzo perché di
questo si ammalano anche i maschi a una
frame una famiglia e frenabile
indomabile ingestibile e l'unico
strumento che sia per calmare spegnere
questa fame e divorare quello che si
trova a tal punto da riempire lo stomaco
e può essere costretti a vomitare questo
è il viaggio perverso della bulimia
federica penale mi racconta di questa
cosa e come spesso io faccio di fronte a
ragazze che vengono con questo sintomo
mi faccio raccontare la loro
storia quando federica inizia ad
ammalarsi di bulimia e federica mi
racconta una storia particolare che
vorrei condividere perché ci insegna
alcune cose federica si ammala in realtà
all'inizio di anoressia perché di queste
patologie a volte ci sono diverse fasi
di malattia e si ammala di anoressia
quando incontra l'uomo col quale poi
avrebbe condiviso i suoi successivi anni
dal punto di vista sentimentale ma anche
dal punto di vista della quotidianità e
scopre che anche quel ragazzo soffre di
anoressia lo vede mangiare meno lo
vedessero ossessionato dal peso lo vede
essere concentrato dalla sua sulla sua
immagine corporea e anche le inizia a
mangiare meno inizia a pensare che forse
quella modalità di attenzione che quello
a quella persona amata nei suoi compagni
confronti di se stessi una modalità per
prendersi cura di sé e inizia così il
disturbo alimentare di federica che è un
disturbo
inizialmente caratterizzato dalla paura
di mangiare mangio meno mangio meno
mangio meno devo pensare meno rifiuto
devo essere forte io vincere la fame il
soggetto anoressico lotta e vuole
vincere la propria fame poi crolla
perché nessuno di noi biologicamente
nelle condizioni di poter digiunare più
di un certo periodo la propria esistenza
e dall'anoressia si entra la bulimia
federica viene incontrarmi federica mi
chiede aiuto perché le non sopporta
quelle crisi di fame e il vomito che poi
tutto questo produce federica troverà un
luogo dove curare tutto questo che il
luogo della comunità cosa c'è dietro il
rapporto tra noi e il cibo vi porto due
frasi che per me sono state illuminanti
una è una fase storica quella del
filosofo materialista feuerbach che dice
noi siamo ciò che mangiamo fava il bath
dice questa fase la scrive in una in una
introduzione o limba primo libro di
nutrizione umana
lo dice perché critica la filosofia di
artistica e dice signori miei
iniziate a capire che noi siamo
mammiferi siamo esseri biologici in
virtù di quello che mangiamo noi
pensiamo determinate cose anche in virtù
di quello che mangiamo e questo è
fondamentale il mangiare è l'intestino
la pancia condiziona la nostra mente
questo non dobbiamo mai dimenticarlo poi
c'è questa altra bellissima frase di
jacques deridda un filosofo più recente
rispetto a faver banche dice il cibo e
metonimia dell'introduzione cosa ci
spiega questa frase vi siete mai
domandati come noi esseri umani appena
nati iniziamo a conoscere il mondo
qual è il nostro primo organo proprio
obiettivo e inter oggettivo che ci
permette di conoscere ciò che non siamo
noi e la bocca noi iniziamo a conoscere
i colori le consistenze i sapori
attraverso la bocca e attraverso
l'oralità che impariamo a conoscere il
mondo la conoscenza
inizia dalla bocca non dimenticate mai
questo principio
qual è la malattia del nostro secolo
perché oggi in italia più di tre milioni
e mezzo di persone soffrono disturbi del
comportamento alimentare
perché in italia il 40 per cento della
popolazione in sovrappeso o obeso perché
noi siamo malati di una malattia che si
chiama che io ho definito ipertrofia
dell'immagine vi ho portato una
bellissima opera d'arte velásquez las
meninas e un quadro della seconda metà
del seicento perché particolare questo
quadro perché per la scherzi fa una cosa
divertente inquadra l'infante margherita
che la figlia di filippo iv e maria anna
d'austria ma realtà se voi vedete sul
fondo del quadro e chiunque si metta nel
punto di fuga di questa bellissima opera
d'arte può notare uno specchio dove sono
presenti appunto il re filippo iv è la
regina marianna quando voi vi mettete di
fronte allo specchio tutti i giorni
cercate di rendere la vostra immagine
ideale di costruire un ideale di voi che
è diverso da quello che siete
questa è la malattia di questo secolo
essere schiavi di un'immagine che
diventa totalmente la vostra identità le
ragazze che soffrono risi a fanno questo
vogliono un corpo che sostenga
un'immagine che rappresenti il loro
ideale
pensate a quanto noi siamo bombardati
tutti i giorni dalla possibilità di
poter manomettere l'immagine che
offriamo
vi faccio un esempio molti di voi forse
lo avranno sul loro smartphone ma non lo
diranno per reticenza quanti hanno mai
utilizzato quelle applicazioni che vi
consentono di fare un photoshop rispetto
a ciò che apparite nella foto tutti
quanti noi facciamo una chirurgia
estetica dell'immagine la facciamo con i
nostri smartphone
noi vogliamo costruire la nostra vita
attraverso la nostra immagine ma il cibo
non è solo qualcosa che sostiene la
nostra mente la nostra vita e la
conoscenza
vi siete mai chiesti perché non ci
svegliano al mattino e facciamo
colazione
pranziamo intorno alle 12 alle 13 a
seconda che le varie latitudini di
provenienza e poi magari facciamo uno
spuntino a metà pomeriggio e poi magari
chiudiamo la giornata con una cena
noi siamo mammiferi e come tutti i
mammiferi dovremmo avere il nostro
comportamento alimentare orientato dalle
nostre esigenze biologiche si abbassa la
glicemia
cerchiamo cibo abbiamo offerto cerchiamo
cibi più grassi estate cerchiamo i
cereali no la nostra alimentazione
un'alimentazione assolutamente
indipendente da quello che il nostro
fabbisogno biologico benedetto da norcia
quello famoso delle regole ora et labora
è colui che ha stabilito i tempi
attraverso i quali noi occidentali
mangiamo quando mangiamo mentre mangiamo
noi confermiamo l'ordine sociale al
quale apparteniamo
noi confermiamo delle regole di comunian
di comunità e questo interessante
ribadirlo freud quando parla di come il
rapporto tra noi esseri umani si
struttura e parte sempre da un rapporto
di dipendenza parla
dell'allattamento qual è l'altra
particolarità del mammifero umano e
mammifero mano nasce ed è assolutamente
alla mercé dell'altro non è capace di
procacciarsi il cibo da solo qualsiasi
altro mammifero dopo tre quattro cinque
attimi dalla nascita è capace di poter
mangiare quasi indipendentemente dalla
madre
noi no e questo dice freud fa sì che il
cibo rappresenti quell'oggetto
mitologico che fa da mediatore tra noi
la vita e l'importanza della presenza
della figura di accudimento della madre
ma il cibo e memoria
prost vi ricordate quel bellissimo passo
in cui lui prende i biscotti le indie
del tè e si ricorda della amata nonna
ogni qualvolta noi mangiamo stimoliamo
la nostra memoria stimoliamo i ricordi
ci riappropriamo della nostra storia
fede di country in comunità e federica
fa due cose si confronta con altre
ragazze che hanno avuto quel tipo di
problema
ascolta le storie di altre ragazze che
hanno l'anoressia ascolta le storie di
altre ragazze che hanno la bulimia
federica sente sente parla con le equipe
parla col suo psicologo parla col suo
psichiatra racconta la sua storia è un
certo punto capisce che il problema non
è il cibo il suo quesito è perché io
sono al mondo perché dopo un anno e
mezzo dalla mia ma dalla mia nascita mia
madre mio padre si sono lasciati perché
io ho un ricordo di questa famiglia così
conflittuale un bimbo che dovrebbe
essere il frutto dell'amore viene al
mondo e invece conosce su il conflitto
federica capisce che il suo disagio
psichico la sua storia particolare viene
in qualche modo messa da parte e il cibo
diventa l'alibi su cui proiettare il
proprio malessere c'è questa bellissima
frase sempre di de rita che dice il fu
di mj che può essere tradotto in tre
modalità bisogna pur mangiare il
rapporto col cibo e ineludibile il
rapporto con l'altro ineludibile e ciò
che rappresenta il cibo è ineludibile
bisogna mangiare bene si diceva prima
l'atto del nutrimento e un atto di
scelta nel mentre noi scegliamo cosa
mangiare compiamo un atto soggettivo
dove noi siamo autenticamente noi stessi
bisogna mangiare il bene e qui vi regalo
un punto che per me è stato fondamentale
qualche anno fa obama disse in una delle
sue tante conferenze il cambiamento
climatico inizia sulla punta della
vostra forchetta quando si mangia non si
mangia solo per sé ma nell'atto della
scelta del cibo questa cosa incide anche
sugli equilibri del mondo e c'è tutto un
filone oggi di ricerca che mette in
correlazione le scelte alimentari con
l'aumento della produzione di co2 che
siamo mangiatori compulsivi oppure
restrittivi e controllanti in realtà noi
quando mangiamo entriamo in risonanza
con l'altro con chi è di fronte a noi
con l'altro in carne ed ossa con l'altro
che ci circonda le scelte alimentari
hanno a che fare con le strade che
percorriamo ogni giorno nelle nostre
città col mondo che viviamo con la
natura che dobbiamo rispettare ma vi
lascio con un'altra piccola provocazione
qual è il piatto tipico di rovigo
non sento polenta prendiamo un piatto di
polenta
immaginate un piatto di polenta e voi da
soli seduta a tavola che mangiate questo
buon piatto di polenta ora stessa
medesima scena stesso piatto di polenta
voi con una tavola con gli amici del
cuore con le persone amate con le
persone piacevoli quale delle due cene
produrrà più sazietà quella in cui avete
mangiato da soli o quella in cui avete
mangiato con le persone a voi care
la seconda quando mangiate mangiate
sempre con chi vi sta a cuore o con
qualcuno con cui parlare guardare negli
occhi perché ogni qualvolta prenderete
una forchetta prenderete un boccone di
cibo state mangiando la vostra storia le
vostre sensazioni la vostra conoscenza
state mangiando la vostra vita grazie
[Applauso]